a dramatic and for the short flight from
Izmir to Istanbul the Boeing owned by
Pegasus Airlines was touching down when
pilots appear to have lost control the
plane veered off the runway burst into
flames and broke into pieces
most of the 171 passengers along with
the crew miraculously escaped alive many
suffered injuries and was sent to
hospitals the two pilots reported to be
in a serious condition an investigation
is underway to determine the causes of
the crash Molotov unfortunately the
Pegasus Airlines plane could not stay on
the runway due to poor weather
conditions and skidded for around 50 to
60 meters it fell from 30 to 40 meters
175 passengers two babies for flight
attendants and two pilots were on board
120 passengers have so far been
transferred to nearby hospitals there
was a thunderstorm bringing gusty winds
at the time of the incident the
authorities closed the airport and
diverted flights to different
destinations this isn't the first time
Pigasus has been involved in such an
incident two years ago one of its Jets
skidded off the runway at Robson Airport
and ended up halfway down a steep slope
by the Black Sea all 162 passengers and
crew aboard were evacuated safely
Pegasus Airlines is likely to face
further scrutiny in the coming days last
month one of its planes slid off the
runway at Sabiha gökçen Airport
investigators said the incident was due
to bad weather conditions
Hoshi Mohammed Al Jazeera Istanbul